Allen kailash's weeks going to do both
lectures Alan Kay has forgotten more
about how to invent the future then that
would make a very bad class with others
this year although which we reasonably
in restore it I like how Nader the group
of incredible teacher scientists and it
I think is the person who had been most
bubbles probably as anyone I've ever met
about how you build organizations to do
to do real innovation so thank you very
much for coming in I am super excited
great Sam so well I'm thoughtful about
it because I got to watch masters do it
I'm basically a research scientist but I
was interested in the process done by
far better managers than me who could
deal with larger sets of ideas and I'll
try and give you a gist here basically I
think because people are here because
they're they want to do startups and
make money I just want to point out that
if want to make money don't bother with
a startup create an industry because
then you get trillions instead of
billions so it's about a factor of a
thousand between doing invention over
innovation in other words not going
incrementally from the present but
carving out a whole new set of ideas
that creates an entirely new context and
we'll see some of the ways to go about
it and we'll also see some of the
barriers and see if this now this got a
bad user interface because it has the
back button here to the front button if
that works so a lot of what these two
days are about are talking about the
place that most people naturally live
which is the present but the problem
with the president is is so glittery and
distracting there's so much stuff going
on it's hard to think about anything
except the present and if you're
thinking about the present your ideas
are going to be
derive from the present and therefore
they're going to be incremental and
therefore you wind up doing innovation
that's you can't make money that way but
today I'm going to do my the opposite of
my usual order I usually like to build a
lot of context first but I thought in
the spirit of the Harvard Business
School and the equivalent at Stanford
I'd start off with things like results
and process and methods first so you
have a feeling that I'm actually saying
something that you might quote unquote
apply but the important talk is really
on Thursday I'm still struggling with
making it the right size so today we're
going to do that and I urge you to copy
my email address I love emails we're not
going to have time to have the
discussion we should have here I welcome
any questions and by the way while I'm
talking I welcome questions at any time
don't be shy okay and here's why school
pisses me off great man in our field
Marvin Minsky observed that this is the
best place ever to keep you from ever
thinking about anything for long enough
so you don't want to try and learn in a
classroom it's terrible in fact I I
don't like to do classroom process
partly because of the time constraints
but also because it's oral we might as
well be sitting around a campfire under
a thousand years ago and almost
everything that's happened that's
important in the last several thousands
of years has been basically literary
inform okay so one of my favorite
picasso sayings and he met a lot of
different things by this part of it is
the best you can ever do with any kind
of representation is make a kind of a
map even when you're trying to make a
map of its of a map you're making a lie
compared to the thing you're trying to
represent but if you do it right
people can
gain some intuition about what the map
is about that's what science is all
about and this talk in 50 minutes has to
be a lie
it really is I'm leaving out a lot of
important things and but I think the the
shadow of the talk or whatever is
projected by the talk it is pretty close
to the way things actually are for doing
this very different process and the
thing that Picasso didn't say but he
knew and he meant is art is also the lie
that tells the truth that wakes you up
so if something wakes you up in the next
two days I will have done my job and
then the two days are really about
another Picasso quote which is learn the
rules like a pro so you can break them
like an artist and not doing this is
probably the greatest sin of Silicon
Valley since the 80s
almost never not nobody has bothered
becoming a pro particularly in software
and user interface design and so when
they break the rules they're breaking
them like a dumb child does by throwing
rocks through windows
it's probably the most sickening thing
to see about the field so another way of
thinking about the mantra is you have to
learn everything and then find a way of
forgetting it so you can have your own
ideas but what you forget is everything
except the perfume so when you have an
idea then your nose will pick up the
right scent and you be able to make use
of all the stuff that you've learned
after you've had the idea now I
specifically asked to talk about Xerox
PARC because that was an example of
making trillions instead of billions and
so I thought what I'll do here is just
show you a couple of results from Xerox
PARC and I'll then try to give you some
of what it took to to get those results
so zahrk's park is known for this
machine that happened I gave one to Sam
he got it working with the help of some
really great people so this machine
happened in 1973 which is 11 years
before the Mac and it's screen was more
than twice the size of the Mac and it
was more like a Mac of 1988 or 1989 so
is about maybe 15 or 16 years ahead of
the commercial development and the
commercial development actually was
based on the stuff that was done on this
machine so this is an example of the
best way to predict the future is to
invent it there's nothing like this
before
once we did it people could see oh yeah
there could be something like this
because here it is exactly made 2,000 of
these so there's a lot to look at they
had bitmap screens they had pointing
device the famous GUI just you're still
using today
WYSIWYG means what you see is what you
get
desktop publishing and the whole media
gig what does that say ah
just not helping me anybody read that oh
yeah symmetrical reading and writing
meaning what you almost never get on the
web but that you did get in many of the
apps of the 1980s which is when you get
a document the thing that you read the
document which also allows you to edit
the document so if you think about the
web it's actually much more made for
consumption than it is made for
authoring they're completely decoupled
and most of the authoring facilities are
typing in tiny little windows and then
pushing a button to see what you did so
this is a vast retrogression what we
call real loop these days we just called
it object-oriented programming back then
I made up that term but what's called
object-oriented programming today is not
what we had back then
and I don't think I'll have time to
really talk about
the profound differences so if ice to
say that what we did at part became
popular and everybody wanted it even if
they only got the label comparison is
you can go out and buy a set of designer
jeans with the label Harvard on them and
for all I know that was Stanford on them
laser printer main difference between
this and what you have today is it was
the first one was a page a second so
most people have never printed with a
page of second printer PostScript
outline fonts and so forth the Ethernet
pure pure and client-server and 50% of
the eat the internet Park did an
internet before there was the internet
and we're part of that community so we
participated in the official internet so
we think of that as eight and a half
inventions how long did it take well 25
researchers for five years think about
that two dozen people did all of these
things in about five years cost about 10
million to 12 million bucks a year in
today's money return is about 35
trillion this is an old number it's
probably more like 40 now that's pretty
good return on investment
think about it you like to do little
spreadsheets and stuff 15% is good right
Sam yeah so it was an industry rather
than an increment people say well but
Xerox didn't benefit from this they
didn't make a money for this complete
is made up by companies that
don't want to invest in research Xerox
made about a factor of 250 over their
entire investment in Park so that's
25,000 percent return right there Xerox
was bug was they in understand the rest
of the stuff but they certainly
understood what a laser printer was and
they made billions from it
in fact if you look at it was better for
the world that the Stonewall does
because what no single company can
handle an entire industry so this made
it possible the Japanese had to do
printers slightly differently than that
and this kind of heaven on earth were
lasted for about 12 years
sharks finally fired the guy who made it
all happen you're thinking he would have
been rewarded right because he made all
the stuff hat but exact they hated him
and they hated them for the very reason
that most companies hate people who are
doing something different because it
makes middle management and upper manage
account full blast and they want to do
is make trillions what they want to do
is make a few millions in a comfortable
way and so this leads to an enormous
problem that where the real job of upper
management in the twenty and twenty
first century is to learn things because
change is the constant thing that's
going on what they try to do is to
maximize whatever they had when they got
into the job and whatever the company
was successful at think about it if
large companies were actually rational
there'd never be a small company
there's nobody know startups because
large companies have vastly more
resources for doing new things than any
venture capitalists right Sam to cut
gazillions of money but because they
refused to get into new businesses and
refused to change their old businesses
you guys have a chance so just pray that
they don't ever wake up now the
interesting thing is if you look at that
collection of inventions you see every
single one of them today and what's
interesting is if I were to enlarge this
a bit I would show that there's hardly
been anything interesting invented
since this funding stopped so it's been
a new basically nuclear winter of people
cashing in on these inventions and
extracting the wealth from them but
hardly any efforts of any interesting
kind to go beyond and the last point
here is the lack of curiosity Sam is a
huge bet Sam because he wanted to he
wanted to know where'd all this stuff
come from I've hardly ever been asked
that question the most successful
generation of wealth in computing
history and almost nobody wants to know
Sam did and the difficult thing about
today and Thursday is the world that you
grew up in because I don't see anybody
is anybody here older than 35 okay yeah
I see a little a little more
reflectivity back there yeah so almost
everybody in the room grew up in a world
that was unlike the world I'm going to
just tell you about now so it's just
many many things were qualitatively
different in ways that are sometimes
difficult to explain so here's the book
to read this is why lectures suck this
is a 500 page book done very carefully
about the whole story of ARPA and Xerox
PARC anybody who's really interested
read this book yeah this is a tribute I
wrote to this whole research community
about 14 15 years ago and I'm going to
hand it out at the end of the class and
the main thing that's interesting about
it perhaps is the bibliography which has
a lot of references on more detailed
things you can read about how this
particular community operated right and
the important thing about Xerox PARC
which is not emphasized enough is that
Park was just another one of the ARPA we
search projects so there's eight years
of research before Park happened and
Park only happened because of the
Vietnam War
nobody wanted to try to do this stuff
inside of a company the company
quarterly cycles and everything else are
really antithetical to long-range
thinking so this stuff was all funded by
Cold War funds in the public domain so
none of none of the IP was kept secret
but it was done in a in a better rhythm
and so to get the 35 trillion it
actually required not five years but
twelve to fourteen years we were the
lucky researchers who got our PhDs in
this process and we're the right age to
go to Park and finish it off right and
as we'll see I'm not going to dwell on
it much more but the zeitgeist of this
way of doing things goes back to the
rate especially the radar effort at MIT
then the air defense effort in then ARPA
and then Park so there's a long
continuity here of kind of how do you
work on things that are that are doable
but where you have to invent several
generations of technology to get to the
thing that's doable so most of these
things are not doable with the
technology that's lying around that is
the the problem with these hard problems
okay so the general world the normal
world the present for most of this
period was either punch card accounting
machines or their replacement after IBM
said famously they'll know there's no
room for more than five or six computers
in the entire world they wound up doing
the first mass-produced computer the
1401 first computer I ever programmed to
replace their punch card machines before
other computer companies
they did a report of a trump-like
reversal on their belief and wound up
owning the 60s and much of the 70s and
most important thing and this is a dumb
sentence because you don't know what
these machines were like so I realized
after I put it in there that why did I
even put this sentence in right but the
way I look at what's going on at any
given time whether it's today 30 or 40
years ago is whatever's going on right
now is is just crap by definition if we
know about it except in the one tenth of
one percent or one thousandth of 1% it's
gotten mundane and part of it is just
because of the bell curve of normality
in humans whatever it is it gets
converted to something like normal no
matter how exciting it is and so when
things are widely successful they tend
to bring up the mean of the bell curve a
little bit for everybody raises all
boats but in fact there's also this
regression to the mean on almost all of
these things so living in the present
man you're out of just out of it if
you're trying to think about things from
what we have now now the there are two
processes there's the bomb project and
the radar project at MIT that had
roughly the same process roughly the
same difficult you have to realize the
US was in World War two for only about
two and a half years I Pearl Harbor was
December of 1941 and so we had 42 43 44
three and a half years and a lot of
things got done the most interesting
thing is for the first time in history
really a lot of really good scientists a
lot of really good engineers started
working together
and cloning each other so seven Nobel
Prizes came out of the building 20 thing
because they were physicists who put on
their engineering hats to make a hundred
and eighty five different kinds of radar
systems and install them in every size
of building and plane and boat and World
War two was basically a war of supply
and it was the ability to stave off the
German submarines that actually won the
war for us most people don't think of it
that way but that's what happened
so the zeitgeist I'm talking about came
out of this group and there's a couple
of good books about how these people
went about doing things maybe the number
one thing is what I have on the right
hand side is basically said forget about
your egos and I really meant it doesn't
matter who you are how smart you are how
smart you think you are this there's
only one thing that counts here is
making progress and we make progress
through synergy and they learned how to
do this and they passed it on generation
after generation well the next round of
this after World War two was the Cold
War and the air defense system that was
done in the 50s and again at MIT
the first displays that you could
interact without that is essentially a
stylus in the guy's hand it was called
the light gun so he's pointing at
something on the screen and squeezing
the trigger like you would put a stylus
down and push it down and the light gun
can tell a computer can tell what the
light gun is looking at and so you can
do all of the stuff that you're used to
today to give you an idea of what these
guys did I can't really see what this is
right it's just like it's obviously four
floors of a building this is the
football field and you notice the second
floor there it says computer a and
computer B each one of those computers
had 50,000 vacuum tubes
both running the same programs at the
same time and many other interesting
things they don't have time to talk
about but I'll just say that when one of
these computers started crashing it took
it three or four days to crash and the
reason is that was running Diagnostics
on itself and every time an instruction
failed you would patch in a simulated
instruction based on what's directions
were still working so what what happens
the machine would just get slower and
slower and more software like more like
a Turing machine usually they could fix
it before it came all the way down
meanwhile the other one was still
working but even though I shouldn't be
digressing there's a fun thing here
there are 32 of these concrete bunkers
made so the two interesting things what
happened to this stuff anybody knows
this looked like anything you've ever
seen before
no that's but yeah yeah this actually
was the invention of our air traffic
control system that's what it was
designed to do but except it's designed
to control traffic of both American and
Russian bombers and in fact if many of
the displays before they replace them
with flatscreen displays with us
basically the same big round things so
this whole system lasted until 1982 when
one was finally decommissioned and
50,000 vacuum tubes they're like
incandescent light bulbs they blow out
so they're always blowing out so of
course they were redundant ones there
where do we get the vacuum tubes from
think about all the way through the
seventies huh no no this is vacuum no
transistors in these machines no
transistors easily
absolutely how did you know that yeah
that's that's good at your remember
that's good yeah for the last 12 or 18
years of this defense system which was
never used against the Russians ever
because they never tried to bomb us and
was actually obsolete very soon because
of ICBMs it couldn't track them there's
a whole nother system for doing that
yeah but we kept it going and there are
reasons why I got was kept going
we bought while we're still contending
in the Russian for the cold cold where
were spying vacuum tubes from them too
and by the way people still keep by back
and tubes from the Russians for getting
old 50s guitars amp sounds those over
driven sounds and this guy who was one
of the inventors of artificial
intelligence and the inventor of the
programming language list John McCarthy
looked at one of these in the 50s and
said everybody's going to have one in
their home someday because he didn't
give a about the concrete bunkers
and anything else like that because what
he thought was yeah this is like we get
was like an electric power generating
station nobody ever sees them but
they're out there
we got wires going into the home for
it's like where we get our water from
it's where we get our gas from so
utilities so he thought oh they'll be
being information utility and it will
actually be a human right like the
telephone to have one of these things in
your home that is connected to all the
world's information so that was one of
the earliest and most influential ideas
1962 I'm going to show you a system done
on one of these supercomputers this is
done on the test computer at Lincoln
labs for this whole sage system so it's
this computer was close to the size of
this entire building
with one guy on it at 3 o'clock in the
morning so take a look at this this is
Ivan Sutherland so it doesn't even
really have a display it's actually
simulating a computer display here this
is just an oscilloscope so what Ivan
wants to do is to draw a flange and so
he says okay it's kind of like this now
take these guys and make them all
mutually perpendicular and Wow
sketch bad just solve that problem so
it's a dynamic problem solver in their
first window that clipped now he wants
to put a hole in the flange so these are
guidelines the first thing he does is
said okay I want to make these parallel
and see sketch pad keeps them on the
line there and lines them up and now
he's using them as guidelines to draw
dashed lines you see here he misses but
okay okay and now he makes the
guidelines invisible they're still there
the constraint was collinearity there
and he has a knob to continuously zoom
so this is the first computer graphics
ever and he wants the rivets to go in go
along with that flange and so again he
is why this system is called sketch pad
because you guys casually draw it's
going to use that as the Center for the
arc here and again he's going to say
take these guys and make them mutually
perpendicular and here's sketch grad
solves that problem so you wind up with
a symmetric object and it can
change things and he'll get another
solution
he could have constrained the size
lengths to be ratios of each other and
the kind of problem solving this system
could do were included nonlinear
problems today or ease getter a rivet
and what's cool about this that is a
master rivet what we call a class and
object-oriented programming so this is
not that rivet but an instance of that
master rivet my wonder why is the
display bouncing around like that well
it's putting up every dot individually
and about half the power of this
supercomputer is being used to just do
that so here's another instance of the
rivet here's another one here's another
one and he says what I didn't want to
have those crossbars there so I'll go
back to the master rivet and make the
crossbars in invisible they're still
there but invisible and we see the
instances so this is object-oriented
programming may be nicer than you've
seen it get rid of those guys and now
that construction that he made he's made
it into a master and so he can make
instances of it okay
get the idea yes sort of regressed here
well anybody in this class ever seems
get back before okay so that's hardly
answer
yeah well we'll take that go a lot it's
sort of the larger question that we have
- it's worthwhile bringing up the
question he's rotating three of them so
this is the most shocking thing I'd ever
seen when I went to graduate school in
66 this was system was only three years
old at that time and I've been
programming for five years and just
conventional programming and seeing this
it blew my mind because it was exactly
different than everything I thought
about computing as soon as I saw it I
realized oh yeah of course you can do
that but I didn't think about that Ivan
did okay so sketch pad interactive
computer graphics in a way we recognized
today for the first time objects masters
and instances the programming was not
done by the kind of programming today
but by problem solving which I think it
can imagine is much nicer like it will
find a solution and it creates automatic
dynamics of simulation so it's not just
for drawing bridges when you draw the
bridge in it knows how to simulate the
bridge and tell you what the stresses
and strains are so I said to Ivan Ivan
you did all of this and what does those
PhD thesis said you told us in one year
by yourself how could you possibly do it
in he said well I didn't know it was
hard he just went after what the problem
is and if you read his thesis and you
should because you can see there are
things that are of absolute goodness
still today it's not just relatively
good for for being done more than 50
years it's absolutely good and his
thesis is every other page as an apology
because it doesn't do more because Ivan
was working on the problem he wasn't
working on what you could do is working
on the problem
yeah so sketchpad was a bombshell in
this research community was about to
happen because right away you were
looking at the future you just had to
believe that a room saw a building sized
computer was going to wind up on a
laptop or even something in a desk so
the other the main player here back then
was a guy by the name of lick lick
lighter the ARP and he got given some
money in 1962 by ARPA before the D and
whenever but anybody asking what are you
going to do this is what you'd say
computers are destined to become
interactive intellectual amplifiers for
everyone in the world universally
network worldwide you would not say
anything more simply gave that money now
here's some bullet points I hate bullet
points but this is a perfect class I
think to put bullet points in and I
found 16 that will tell you just what
you have to do and I've thought of a few
cents but 16 is more than enough so the
first thing was just picking an idea
that's worth dedicating your life if
necessary to so this stuff was human
destiny fixing big human problems like
we can't think very well we need to make
things to help us to think we need to
make things to help us cooperate so
these are save the world kind of ideas
and they were done when you know the
Russians were starting to test hydrogen
bombs and things did not look so good
forget about goals the problem is the
goals tend to be much more idiosyncratic
to individual humans so research wants
to be a vision so notice aren't any
goals in the ARPA dream and that allowed
Lickliter to fund 15 or 20 super smart
people who thought they
had ways of approaching the dream and
some of these people didn't agree and
some of them hated each other and look
didn't give a he would just wanted
smart people working on this dream so
fun people not projects ARPA never
decided and we'll see a slight
modification of this but basically fun
people not projects going to do that you
better have the very best people so if
you know MacArthur grants are for
individuals but this funding was funding
groups like you funded MacArthur it's
just five years forget it
nobody in MacArthur asks you never you
don't get a second MacArthur grant here
they would get another grant if they've
done something good in five years but
basically idea of MacArthur is throw
away we've identified this person of
extreme potential let's just give them
five years of funding and we won't
cry if they don't do anything turns out
most MacArthur people do do something
because the people that attract
attention are people who are not working
for money they're doing it because they
must there are people like artists are
people who do their art because they
must yeah community not a project you
have to fund problem finding this really
dries funders crazy today what I mean by
that
most of the time when you're working on
hard problems you don't know what the
right problem is this why visions are
really good divisions are detached if
you pick a problem too early you might
be picking it out of the current context
and therefore you're going to be
hampered unless you're incredibly lucky
so art but put a lot of money into just
people around with stuff
milestones not deadlines baseball not
golf meaning when you lose a stroke in
golf you cry when you strike out in
baseball you better not cry
because you're going to do it a lot and
this is what Lickliter said to them he
said look if you're batting 350 in
baseball you're really doing well and if
you look at what we're funding if we bat
350 we're going to change the world
that's what happened
nobody cares about all the stuff that
didn't work and people said well what
about the 65 percent failure and they
say well it's not failure in baseball
it's overhead hitting a ball is hard
when you're doing something really
really hard the times you don't do it
well is just overhead for doing it the
times you do well this is the probably
the biggest distinction that business
people do not understand because what
they want is actually teeny little
uninteresting projects that are
guaranteed for success but sports is
right in front of it Sports is out
really hard and most sports people are
not succeeding all the time the thing
what's the thing in anybody know
baseball here what's the thing in
baseball it's called an era it's like
what oh just feeeeel yeah what's an era
in baseball not catching a fly ball how
good are the average fielders they're
98.5 percent effective so really good
ones are like 1% error and so an error
in technical stuff is designing to build
a computer system and failing to build
it like anybody should be able to design
the build a software system and failing
to build it you just should deal with
knock that off but you're in this other
range when you're trying to do design
it's really two different things so
here's a memo lick wrote in 63 shortly
after you got this initial money from
ARPA to members and affiliates of the
intergalactic computing network and they
asked him why did you call it that you
said well engineers always give you the
minimum and I want a network that spans
the entire planet
asking for an intergalactic one and when
they scale it down we'll still get so
that's where the internet came from
literally the original name of the
internet was the intergalactic computing
nobody knew how to do it back then
packet for instance packet switching had
not been invented in 63 and here's a
nice line in that memo if we succeed in
making intergalactic Africa our main
problem will be learning to communicate
with aliens and you mean mentis in the
biggest possible way and I don't have
time to really explain it it's really
interesting people who are interested in
this should write me an email didn't
mean just other people you man other
software other computers meant what does
it mean to communicate when you scale
things up so this guy was a big thinker
number 9 you can't think inside the
beltway that's of course referring to
Washington DC but this is a general
principle they asked him why and he said
well because there's too much noise is
too much politics as too much
and nobody does research in Washington
DC so the last thing we want to do is
our profundas is to trying to think
while we're there our job is to get
money out of the government and pass a
lie and so a solution to that was say
hey let's not be here for longer than
two years and so every two years so look
set up the process to get his successor
happened that Ivan suddenly got drafted
into the Army at just the right time and
so they grabbed him and so at age 26
Ivan ran this whole show and man was he
good so he was a he was a second
lieutenant chairing meetings with
generals in it and one of the most
famous things recalled of that some
general is going on and on at some point
Ivan said general you just you have just
two minutes to make your point if you
have one that's about the simplest way
of describing Ivan Bob Taylor and Larry
Roberts those are the four that made
this happen
Taylor is special because he also was
the guy who set up Park
and he was a student of Licklider
Licklider was intuitively wonderful
Taylor was a student of what was
wonderful about this right and he could
explain everything that Licklider could
do and why it worked so here's a couple
of things I'm not going to go on about
but basically the idea here is it isn't
like let's look around and see what is
available and what we can do with it the
idea was stick with the vision and just
make every frigging thing that's
necessary doesn't matter what it is we
have to make a new kind of integrated
circuit we'll do it all of these things
were done so it's very much like these
other cultures where nobody worried
about whether you had a half-centimeter
radar in building 20 of MIT they just
did it and here's one that is really a
bug today and if you don't have the
chops yeah you shouldn't make your tools
you shouldn't make your own operating
system you shouldn't make your own
programming language because that's not
what you're trying to do if you do have
the chops and you better not do this
unless you have the chops then you have
to make your own hardware and software
and operating system in the programming
languages otherwise you're working in
the past on some vendors bad idea of
what computing is about so part of this
deal may work what Picasso said you have
to get really much much better than most
people wanting today and here's another
reversal today people buy hardware and
put software on it basically make the
hardware look good the arbor community
in part did exactly the opposite started
off with the software using
supercomputers to simulate the thing and
when you got the software the way you
wanted it then you design a computer
that would optimize and make more
efficient what you're doing on a
supercomputer that was what sketch pant
was nobody thought that the next graphic
systems were going to be done on a
computer the size of this building
and then make a bunch of them so almost
every project in the ARPA project they
actually made enough of them so they
could be used as tools they weren't just
demos and so part of this invention
process had to require a kind of limited
engineering our part for instance had a
thing where whatever you did you had to
make a hundred of them bathed in
Ethernet it had to run a hundred
machines from here the time sharing
system it had to run 100 users made a
personal computer you have to be able to
build a hundred of them learn how to
argue this is what you learned as a
graduate student their argue for clarity
not to win
it's the biggest bug today people are
always contending with each other trying
to be winning winners and losers and
that's one of the problems of Washington
they've forgotten what their job is know
what you have to do is understand these
complicated things here's a biggie every
researcher at Parc was a second or
third-generation PhD that ARPA had
created right eight years so it wasn't
just the stuff in the past I'll show you
a couple more of those while we're
getting close to but it was creating the
next generation again this is baseball
baseball you don't you have to have
farms you have to develop talent going
all the way down to Little League and
they did and the other thing is a little
difficult to some of you will understand
this readily that the reward of doing
this stuff wasn't the reward of making
it happen because a lot of times it
didn't happen there was a reward of
actually being funded to work on what
the actual problems were I can't
emphasize this too much working on what
the problems actually are rather than
something that's going to get a paper or
something that's going to make you money
but taking like big human problems
because
could be something like drinkable water
for the 70% of the planet that doesn't
have it doesn't matter there's no other
goal you know if you pick one of those
things that's a great one worth putting
a life into okay so background was
partly tinkering a lot of people came
from New York down where the World Trade
Center was before the World Trade Center
there is about a mile across Manhattan
Island there was nothing but electronic
surplus stores Moe a few Long's put a
dime into the subway and you can go down
there and buy almost anything to mess
around with and that group got used to
everybody was broke so but you could
build your own like there's a kit for to
build your own oscilloscope and if you
wanted in the sillas cope and you're
broke you could get one of these on time
for 30 or 40 bucks and build it and I'm
going to just put these are just washed
out anyway so I'm just going to go past
okay so Moore's Law this is the original
thing in Moore's paper doubling every
year
he picked MOS silicon which is too slow
to make things out of it would get
faster if you made it smaller
here's doubling every two years what
happened the prediction was thirty years
and so what happened was very in line
with doubling every two years to every
18 months and there was physics behind
this this wasn't just an engineering
aspiration and so if you believe this
you had something really worthwhile I'm
going to skip past Engelbart resort I
see it over like that that he's a court
I think you should see a little of this
though at the same time the mouse was
invented this was done it Rand and how
did the ran people go about it well at
midnight they would go through people's
waste paper baskets
to see how they work what were they
throwing away and but what people were
doing when they're working is making all
kinds of diagrams and flowcharts and all
this stuff so they said okay well let's
invent the first tablet as good as most
of the tablets you've ever used today
it's a hallmark of these people is they
generally did it good enough and when
they start to edit the flow diagram
first we erase a flow arrow then move
the connector out of the way so that we
may draw a box in its place the printing
in the box is being used as commentary
only in this case the box is slightly
too large so we may change its size then
draw flow from the connector to the box
attach a decision element to the box and
draw a flow from it to scan we then
erase the flow okay so this is about
1968 or so get on a big room size
mainframe with one guy but this system
really what you could ask you a question
more even about this this system was one
of the best systems I've ever used in
every it felt so intimate it was so
different from the mouse you know it was
one of the things that we that we
actually looked at I guess I do have to
show the next the next thing here just
so you think that VR wasn't something
done recently but the second thing Ivan
done did after he came back the vamp
when he came back from our boat was to
do this I worked on this when I was a
graduate student you could grab things
and have a thing in your hand you grab
things and move them around it it's a
little exciting because instead of the
thing that you used to today in VR it
had
CRTs with 15,000 volts right above your
ears crackling away so it's a very
exciting thing to do and of course one
of the hardest things was to do good
head positioning back then there are
many ways of doing one of the things
they did here I won't explain what it is
but it was hooked to a crane so as you
walked around this big room at MIT a
crane would would automatically
follow you with the positioning thing
over your head to find out what what
this was about and oh man I'm getting
killed because I should stop right now
but I really have two more things to do
if you could give me two more minutes I
will do the first one here is this is
something you have to think about but
time go one way and progress go the
other way
yay boo yay boo goes up it goes down
this is the way people tend to measure
things problems they never put in a
threshold put in a threshold then the
only things above the threshold count
like if these are reading scores they
nothing counts we use Gore's never get
above threshold so it doesn't matter
whether they go up or down and what is
actually needed changes over in time you
need more and if you're measuring to a
baseline which people usually do one of
the ways of improving things or making
it look like you're not doing such a bad
job is to lower the baseline for example
Apple completely lowered the baseline on
what constitutes reasonable the user
interface for iPhones and iPads
interfaces on the systems beforehand had
an undo in these don't and I can name 15
more things think about it so what they
did is they decided well we're just
which is not going to work on all of
those problems anymore we're going to
condition the unsophisticated public to
do work at the level of a two year old
or a 92 year old and we're just going to
eliminate everything in between and the
public has bought it because you don't
want to count noses
when you're looking for quality people
can be talked into anything so what you
have to do on this stuff is you have to
pick something that is absolutely above
that line we call that McCready sweet
spot he's the guy of did man-powered
flight and once you have achieved that
it opens up a whole region that you can
explore it and that's what we did it at
Parc moonshot was set space travel back
50 years everybody uses as a metaphor we
need a moonshot no we don't need a
moonshot you just don't do space travel
with chemical rocketry and what's
interesting about the people who like
Jeff Bezos and yeah you know you want
they don't get it
MV equals envy every child who read
science fiction in the fifties knew this
what that means is either have to carry
a shitload of reaction mass with you if
you're doing chemicals because you can't
get the velocity high enough so you have
to put out a lot of mass and if you do
that you have to lift that mask so you
wind up with 40 five-story building
Rockets just to get into orbit that is
nuts anyway I will not go on that so so
but the thing that was a tragedy was
that there are very good proposals for
how to get that high exhaust velocity
using various forms of atomic power and
was something that the public was not
interested in the moonshot was not about
space travel okay
so I'll skip past this because I want to
end with oh yeah here's it so this
tablet computer I thought up in 1968 it
had two initial forms one was the
familiar tablet the other one was what
Ivan's head-mounted display was
inevitable with Moore's law and then
Nicholas Negroponte had this idea of
wearing a watch and communicating with
the rest of the world okay so here's the
last little segment then alike
go wayne gretzky you know who Wayne
Gretzky is I'll get great at hockey
player everywhere and there's just a
little guy he tried to avoid fights they
asked ask them why it took so many shots
on goal he says well you miss 100% of
the shots you don't take
so he wasn't trying to be careful he
scored more goals than anybody in
history by a thousand so the fact that
his percentage of misses was also high
was irrelevant and they asked him why he
was better than anybody else and he said
well a good hockey player goes to where
the hawk puck he is a great one goes to
where the puck is going to be and he
didn't mean tracking the puck he meant
getting into a place where somebody
could pass him the puck where he could
make a goal so what he did is he looked
at the entire configuration saw where
the future was going to be and went to
that place in there so he could make a
game to invent the future out of this
and so you start off with a cosmic
goodness intuition like for me the
tablet one was good you identify a
favorable exponential like Moore's law
you take the cosmic intuition out 30
years and you ask can we say wouldn't it
be ridiculous if we didn't have this and
see 30 years out 90 30 years away of
course we'll have one that's what that
exponential means and bring it back to
the 10-15 year point and at that point
you can just pay money because that's
also what Moore's law and what returning
means is if you pay a lot of money now
you can make the commodity computer of
10 15 years in the future that's what
the alto was was about 50 times faster
than what you got out of time-sharing
terminal and make a bunch of them and
you intertwine it with so run the
software and then you can do two kinds
of computing in the future one kind of
computing is zillions of experiments
get a user interface that would be
universal for fight now five billion
people and deal with millions of people
you've never who are doing applications
you've never seen before and the other
thing you can do the thing on the right
there is Microsoft Word as it was at
Xerox PARC in 1974 if you optimize the
code you can get what the applications
are going to be ten years out so those
are the two things you can do by doing
this supercomputer thing and it costs
money in today's dollars those Altos
cost about 125 K apiece and we made
2,000 of them think about that got to be
a funder who's serious Xerox went
batshit when we did it they really went
batshit when we wanted to cash them in
but I'll just leave you this since I'm
over time now I'll leave you this as one
of the ways of escaping the present have
a glimmer of an idea take it so far out
that you don't have to worry about how
are you going to get there and then you
just bring it back so instead of
innovating out from the present what you
want to do is invent the future from the
future you go out and live in the future
and bring the future back thank you
[Applause]